guys before video starts as you guys
know the tragic tragic floods in
Pakistan and people are in dire need
thousands of people have lost their
lives please donate in the link below
two brothers and sisters and dear
friends a lot of the times we talk about
how important Salah is but sometimes we
need some kind of a physical evidence or
a metaphysical evidence here is a
testimony of a Russian magician somebody
who's involved in actual Ser this is
what she had to say about Muslims and
how their Salah actually protects them
against seher and other things that
people that don't like you or the
enemies of Islam want to do on you
here's what she had to say then it is
easier to work it is easier to attach an
entity and it is easier to take
possession of a person's mind
does it mean that it's more difficult to
influence a person if he keeps his
thoughts and Purity yes absolutely one
faced with various religions it is very
difficult to influence Muslims they are
in a constant connection with the
aggregor they do Namaz every day and
read prayers on a daily basis they are
constantly under some kind of a dome so
it is very difficult to influence them
when you start impacting a person he
begins to address in a prayer indeed
many of them are very different from
those who come to church only when
everything is bad in their life they
come to pray and then for five years
they forget about God some cannons and
so on Muslims as a rule passionately
believe and passionately give energy to
their aggregore and this aggregor
protects them very well that's why it is
very difficult to work to make any kind
of influence on a true Muslim believer
is this some kind of a good aggregor
well for them yes this aggregore is good
for adults who contribute good energy to
it how do you sense it for instance you
have found an energy trace of such
person what's next do you try to drag
him somehow to visualize this bad and
you fail or how do you do that it
disappears I cannot get a grip on it I
focus on it but something immediately
knocks me out of the flow just like that
or I visualize the person in front of me
clearly and can affect him even at a
mental level but some image is not
created in my mind at all I even look at
a photo reproduce an image but it
vanishes from my mind thus I can clearly
see that a person is covered with
something does this only work with
Muslims it does for me brothers and
sisters sadly we live at a time where as
Muslims we need some kind of a
scientific evidence some kind of an
experiment something so we can have
faith in what Allah tell us but brothers
and sisters Allah has said this before
that indeed our Salah protects us and we
might not know that but to hear a
magician why is it that it has to come
from a position for us to be like oh my
gosh I didn't know that online is
Messengers told us about this now let's
read some verses in the Quran Allah says
in Surah
Allah says he said this is ibiz my Lord
since you made me go straight I swear
that I shall beautify for them evils on
the earth and I shall lead all of them
astray except those of your servants
from among those who are chosen by you
he Allah said this is the straight path
leading to my leading to to me that a
person is chosen by through his Good
Deeds my service are such that you have
no power over them except those of
deviatives who will follow you
that's one verse we go to another verse
in verse 14 same conversation he said
then give me respite until a day when I
will be resurrected he Allah said you
are granted respite he said now that you
have led me astray I will certainly sit
for them in Ambush on your straight path
then I will come upon them from their
front side and from be there behind and
from the right and from the left you
will not find most of them uh find most
of them but grateful brothers and
sisters when we talk about doing our
thicker when we talk about doing and
this is a Salah can be understood in
different ways you know if we look at
the Arabic language subhanallah it can
be a form of Decker Dua or Salah which
we establish brothers and sisters Allah
has physical laws in place meaning like
I said before gravity I let go the phone
fools this is a physical reality Allah
set in place it's a law that is in place
there is also metaphysical laws in place
do you know how many people want to harm
you and dislike you that I want to do
what they already do the evil eye yes
giving you evil eye a jealous envy and
some go to the lengths of doing sir
isn't it interesting that Allah has set
these things in place to protect us even
during your thicker this Russian
magician is saying that when she tries
to focus to harm somebody with the Sahar
that somebody else has got to do it
saying that she goes out of focus
something pulls her out of focus or when
she's trying to harm that person and
that as if that there is a protective
Dome over the person who established
Salah and indeed Allah
his true servants who observe the Salah
will not be harmed by this brothers and
sisters this is just one means there's
just one way of looking at Salah Salah
number one Allah says his true servants
yes humble true servants would establish
Salah brothers and sisters we don't need
this magical said to pray Salah yes that
could be a reason we should be praying
Salah regardless brothers and sisters
just by who Allah is if Allah did
nothing for us if Allah was just to
create us and we was just to stand still
doing nothing to their judgment he
deserves our worship and we know of the
Hadith for the prophet Muhammad
and this is the bitter truth of the
matter brother and sisters we don't want
to praise Allah it's the bitter Salah I
don't have I don't have time I'm busy
with the world Etc can you imagine
what a reality what's a bitter way of
looking at life is that you the one
who's created the heavens and earth and
you and you're like I don't have time
for you it's as if you're saying to
Allah you created me but you wasn't
aware that I'll be busy and you're
telling me to pray Salah what an insult
to the one who's created you
but the truth of the matter is what
brothers and sisters like I said there's
a Hadith for the prophet sallam that
there is a group of angels that Allah
created from the moment that they were
created till the day of Resurrection
they are in prostration you know how we
prostrate for 10 seconds 20 seconds they
are in prostration from the moment they
were created to the moment of
Resurrection
and when they are told to rise up and
put their head up
do you know what they will say to Allah
they will say Oh Our Lord
we did not worship you the way you
deserve to be worshiped
can you imagine they say we did not
worship you the way you deserve to be
worshiped how great he is
how great Allah azzawajal is
How Majestic he is just by him just by
who he is he deserves our worship let
alone all the blessings you have man go
look at your fridge look at your
cupboard look at the bed that you're
sleeping look at the health that you
have and everything that you have
Allah is deserving a worship just for
that just by who he is let alone what he
gives us and let alone the other things
the realities Allah created like say her
magician Envy jealousy evil eye that's
in place that Allah has created us and
that this Salah which you do not know
about protects us
and I'm gonna end on this note
which is the bitter truth brothers and
sisters
imagine under their judgment Allah shows
you the Salah that you prayed the sadaqa
and the zakah that you gave the fasting
that you did and how they were in the
way of so many calamities imagine Allah
showing you that your child was going to
die or something was going to happen to
you or a bus was going to hit you but
there was this thing that you did that
got in the way
how would you feel feeling subhanallah
look how merciful and grateful Allah is
this was just a video for you guys to
inshallah wake you guys up from sisters
Salah is the key and the hack of Allah
no ifs no buts for those who are seeing
that it's hard for them look I
understand start your journey but if I
gave you five thousand pounds to wake up
for Fajr you will not even go to sleep
just so you don't miss the opportunity
Allah is promising you Jannah
forever everything that you wish
whatever you want is going to be there
on that note brothers and sisters we
have launch the salahplus.com go check
it you can book a free session with a
sister from the sisters team Salah
instructor and brother Steve myself and
come at you and teach you how to play
Salah you can also book your free guided
prayer map which teaches you how to pray
and there are videos there that teach
you how to pray step by step on our
solar plus program at Salam please check
that out may Allah bless you guys until
next time